[Musica]
bene sono domenico prattichizzo sono
professore di robotica qui
all'università di siena e sono con due
cari amici alessandro bondi che ho avuto
l'opportunità e il piacere di incontrare
in questi ultimi mesi e giovanni
spagnoletti ingegnere del mio team vi
parlerò di robotica al supporto di
persone che purtroppo hanno subito danni
permanenti da ictus
in particolare noi ci siamo sempre
focalizzati sullo studio delle mani da
sempre nel mio laboratorio abbiamo
studiato la mano umana la mano robotica
tecnologie studio metodi per le mani
qui vedete ci sono le mani di mia figlia
elena di una sua amichetta violante che
lavorano con i mattoncini cosa faranno
li toccano li esplorano lì e lì
afferrano li prendono assemblano per
costruire chissà quale fantasia avevano
immaginato
ed è la mano è l'organo prensile perney
per eccellenza nostra ed è stato il
primo strumento dell'essere umano grazie
al quale abbiamo costruito altri
strumenti e grazie ai quali abbiamo
potuto fare è il tema del fare e
permanente in tutte le in tutte le
presentazioni di oggi abbiamo fatto
strade ponti autostrade comunicazione
tanto non potrei immaginare un mondo
diverso da questo senza le nostre senso
alle nostre mani
bene noi presso il nostro laboratorio ci
occupiamo di robotica e cerchiamo di
creare delle versioni artificiali della
manipolazione qui vedete un sistema di
tele operazione dove c'è una mano
robotica che oggi sta lavorando con gli
stessi mattoncini per riprendere quello
che stava facendo elena e di diana e
violante nel loro nel loro gioco ma è un
sistema di tele operazione cioè un
sistema che permette di remotizzare il
funzionamento della mano altrove
possiamo immaginare ambienti pericolosi
o ambienti contaminati possiamo
immaginare per esempio il disastro di
fukushima dove invece che mandare la
mano di un operatore all'interno del
sito per manipolare una valvola mando un
robot che viene tele operato a distanza
qui vedete le mani di leonardo lenardo
meli uno dei collaboratori del nostro
laboratorio che muove la sua mano aziona
questi robot che che riproducono il
movimento della mano su una mano
robotica da questa parte questa mano
robotica dei movimenti fini guarda te
perchè afferra e mentre afferra questi
oggetti né misura anche ne percepisce
anche le forze che poi vennero vengono
riflesse sulla mano di leonardo sulla
mano dell'operatore sapete benissimo
tutti abbiamo giocato quei mattoncini
che se non c'è una percezione della
forza non si riesce ad assemblare con la
sufficiente stabilità in pezzi per
creare le nostre costruzioni bene vengo
al focus del della giornata alessandro
me e giovanni tre amici collaboratori
che hanno cominciato a lavorare insieme
a tanti altri ora c'è giovanni ma
giovanni rappresenta un gruppo molto
molto ampio e alessandro è una
una persona un amico un soggetto che ha
avuto un ictus
quattro anni fa e purtroppo a causa di
questo ictus a riporta dei danni
permanenti alla all'arto superiore in
particolare alla mano ora lo stroke
l'ictus è una è una piaga
quindi ho riportato dei dati ci sono
circa 2 300 nuovi casi di ictus ogni
100mila abitanti per anno cioè come se
noi a siena avessimo circa 150 persone
che vengono colpite da ictus per anno e
il 60 per cento di queste persone
subisce un danno permanente a e degli
effetti al sistema sensori motori in
particolare all'arto superiore e in
particolare alla mano la mano è un
organo molto importante io faccio sempre
questo esempio non voglio rifare anche
ora
cioè se voi guardate il mio corpo dal
punto di vista motorio dal punto di
vista delle articolazioni il mio corpo è
fatto da due mani la mano sinistra e la
mano destra e da un corpo ok se adesso
dimenticate per un attimo le mani ei
piedi e guardate solamente il mio corpo
io di fatto sono un'altra mano sono un
palmo e quattro dita 1234 e magari il
pollice perché perché guardate questa
spalla questa spalla a due gradi di
libertà in termini di articolazione
esattamente come questa articolazione
qui
ok del nostro dito quest'ultima
articolazione e ha un'articolazione
simile a quella del mio gomito
quindi un braccio è assolutamente
identico dal punto di vista della
complessità motoria
a parte lo scherzetto di di scala e
assolutamente simile un dito quindi io
dal punto di vista motorio o una
complessità sostanzialmente parlo da
robotico di tre mani quindi è chiaro che
se mi succede qualcosa a livello
cerebrale che mi colpisce l'area motoria
la probabilità che venga colpita un'area
preposta al controllo della mano è molto
alta per cui si portano danni permanenti
alla
bene con alessandro voglio sottolineare
che da una collaborazione scientifica è
nata una grande amicizia e alessandro ha
un problema a un problema alla mano
destra e in particolare non riesce più a
fare dei compiti eseguite dei compiti di
manuali non riesce più ad aprire una
bottiglia non riesce più a utilizzare il
tubetto del dentifricio permettere la
pasta sullo spazzolino
tutto ciò che noi facciamo normalmente
con due mani con cercato di guardare in
letteratura in robotica cosa c'era per
lui no e ho trovato cioè per persone che
hanno avuto un xv ho trovato molto
spesso tantissime ricerche che si sono
focalizzate sulle protesi
ora io ho pensato ma il numero di
imputati che è infinitamente minore
rispetto al numero delle persone che
hanno problemi motori a causa del
dell'ictus per esempio della mano però
ad un ciononostante si è sviluppata
tanta tecnologia per le mani le protesi
robotiche che sostituiscono l'arta
mancante in caso di imputati ci sono
delle tecnologie che aiutano le persone
con ictus e sono si chiamano
esoscheletri sostanzialmente sono delle
strutture robotiche che simulano lo
scheletro umano e aiutano con dei motori
elettrici a muovere la mano nel club per
compensare la mancanza diciamo della
delazione muscolare vera ma chiaramente
questo tipo di dispositivi è molto
impegnativo lo posso utilizzare
solamente nei centri di riabilitazione
non posso utilizzarlo a casa
allora abbiamo cominciato a pensare noi
siamo focalizzati molto sulla sulle mani
sulle tecnologie e motori e della
manipolazione e sulla tecnologia per il
tatto abbiamo cominciato a pensare
abbiamo cominciato a riguardarci la mano
per un attimo guardatevi la mostra mano
ora guardate la vostra mano e cominciate
a pensare un attimo a qual è il minimo
numero di elementi di cui voi avete
bisogno per afferrare un oggetto
ok vedo che lei sta usando tre dita
ma qual è il minimo numero di dita per
afferrare un oggetto 2 ma è veramente
211 mille proprio uno perché io in
realtà potrebbe utilizzare il palmo
ok una parte fissa e il pollice
opponibile
che mi stabilizza la presa non è una
presa manipolativa non è una
manipolazione fin hamas fine ma
stabilito un oggetto ed è esattamente
questa l'idea che abbiamo avuto nel
nostro laboratorio di robotica qui a
siena quella di sviluppare uno strumento
robotico che sia un dito in più un sesto
dito un pollice robotico che entra in
funzione solo quando è necessario che
dia ad alessandro e persone che hanno
come lui un bisogno di utilizzare la
mano di nuove l'aca di nuovo la capacità
di presa la capacità di afferrare questa
volta ibrida parzialmente fatta dal
corpo umano e l'altra parte invece è
fatta da una parte robotica quindi non
c'è bisogno di sviluppare una mano
robotica completa ma un semplice dito
opponibile il pollice opponibile quello
grazie alla quale noi possiamo
realizzare delle prese questo è il
nostro robotics finger è un dito
soprannumerario ed è realizzato con
tecnologie indossabili poi lo vedremo
funzionare questo titolo abbiamo fatto
estremamente indossabile quella era la
primissima versione di qualche anno fa
questo titolo è diventato un
braccialetto e un braccialetto che sta
sotto la giacca e che alessandro mette
in posizione e che passa da posizione
docking posizione di working mode o al
solo quando lui ne ha bisogno per cui
col con la mano ancora diciamo abile
quindi la mano intatta riesce a mettere
il dito robotico in posizione di lavoro
e quindi riesce a fare le prese cosa
riesce a fare riesce a fare questi task
guardate riesce ad afferrare le
barattoli bottiglie riesce ad aprire a
togliere il tappo oppure ad aprire
pacchetti di patatine o addirittura a
spezzare il pane recuperando la capacità
di manuale che ora non ha più a causa
dell'effetto dello dello stroke qui in
questo particolare caso il caso c'è un
elemento interessante abbiamo sviluppato
un anello per controllare il movimento
del dito questo anello anche una
capacità robotica perché è nel caso di
poesia si può avere a causa di un ictus
non sono un problema motorio ma anche un
problema percettivo la ipo estesi a
riduce la capacità di percepire quindi
quando io ho un dito robotico e afferro
non so quanta forza c'è se non ciò
sensibilità
allora noi riflettiamo su questo anello
la forza della presa
per cui lui sente sulla parte
controlaterale l'effetto della presa
fatto col dito ok quindi in qualche modo
è un'interfaccia sensorimotoria di
questo extra lindt
per lui questo è molto bello l'ho
preparato per per alessandro prime prove
alessandro è un po teso a un certo punto
lui dice no non ce la posso fare
lo rimette lì ci si lavora adesso erano
le primissime prove quando alessandro
non riusciva a mettere la marmellata
sulla fetta biscottata no non ce la
posso fare
in realtà poi lui è realizzato molto
abile lasciato l'auto lui ora questa
volta il nero un successo rieste riesce
a spalmare la marmellata sulla fetta
biscottata tra l'altro abbiamo imparato
tantissime cose
una delle cose che abbiamo dovuto fare
per queste dita e farlo è waterproof
perché alessandro così come tutte le
persone che parlano il nostro
laboratorio vogliono utilizzare il video
per esempio per stabilizzare la base
della moka e metterci in rete
quindi c'è bisogno e scherzi che sia
resistenti all'acqua e questa volta non
è riuscito in bocca e finalmente riesce
a fare questo tipo di operazione
guardate che motivare una persona come
alessandro a muovere il proprio braccio
e tutto beneficio perché come si diceva
come diceva il soul fatica prima a
tenere in movimento di rabarama gesti
del piano anche
un ambito riabilitativo qui vediamo
ancora un task importante che alessandro
sta facendo in particolare sta
sbocciando una mela cosa che si riesce a
fare anche in modo in tasca difficili e
anche per persone abili con tutte e due
le mani
sbucciare la mela e farne dei pezzettini
non è una cosa proprio così semplice
richiede abilità manipolative elevate e
in questo caso alessandro riesce con
questo extra finger a stabilizzare
l'oggetto sbucciare la mela e farne
delle delle delle fettine
un'altra cosa che voglio farvi vedere
con questo altro soggetto che anche
molto interessante noi compensiamo il
funzionamento della mano ma di fatto
riabilitiamo il braccio le persone che
non hanno la capacità di afferrare con
il sesto dito tendenzialmente tendono il
braccio e la mano all'interno della
tasca per cui diciamo buttando giù tutto
il sistema muscolo stelle scheletrico
perché non tenendolo il modello in
movimento il braccio ma fondamentalmente
diciamo giu se perde la sua la sua
efficacia e non è una cosa assolutamente
buona per nessuno e in particolare per
persona che devono hanno bisogno di di
riabilitazione quindi diciamo con questo
sestu dito si riprende motivazione a
rimuovere il braccio stiamo anche
studiando delle capacità del sesso dito
non solo di compensazione della funzione
ma anche di di riabilitazione
vi faccio vedere l'ultimo video prima di
passare la parola ad alessandro
alessandro qui sta utilizzando il sesto
dito
e siccome non aveva tanto attento nel
braccio abbiamo aggiunto anche il terzo
braccio che l'aiuta
rigori abitativo a sollevare il braccio
ad andare ad arrivare all'altezza della
testa e lui vedremo come download del
video
riuscirà a pettinarsi che non sia
sfuggito esterna la spazzola e poi con
la volenza grida anche il terzo braccio
riesce a raggiungere il livello della
testa proprio grazie alla riabilitazione
che rimanendo anche in centri
specializzati
lui ora rispetto a quando l'ha
conosciuto ha molta più potenza del
braccio per cui era ci farà vedere con
il sesso dico cosa farei ma non fa
questa utilità o per controllare e
stesso dito un cappellino dove ci sono
delle ed di elettrodi di amici che
raccolgono la vitalità del bruscolo
trionfalistico
basta notare solo giulia si attiva una
parola tinta elettrone catturata questo
fa partire le terme l'interruttore che
fa partire stata ok alessandro forse
possiamo passare alla tua performance
grazie alessandro ora sta utilizzando il
sesto dito che abbiamo semplificato
nella versione da portare qui alte di
siena
cioè non ha interfacce e come vedete
alessandro riesce a ad aprire la
bottiglietta ad afferrarla con l'extra
finger ad aprire la bottiglietta a fare
qualunque cosa noi voglia fare e poi
rimetterlo a posto
aprire il dito e metterlo in funzione
alessandro forse ci puoi fare qualche
commento lavori eco alessandro di farci
un commento sulla sua esperienza
io ho perso l'uso da parte destra non
guardate ora ma avevo ho difficoltà nel
parlare e quindi sono obbligato a
prendere appunti la neuroscienza un
prato inizio nata per caso se protratta
nel tempo danno un po di speranza a
quelli come me che hanno bisogno di
aiuto per fare le cose quotidiane con il
terzo dietro che inizialmente mi
sembrava potesse servire anche a poco
evento in grado di tagliare una mela
aprire una bottiglia un barattolo o
perché no portare una borsa perché no
porta una borsa della spesa avendoli
della per ogni evenienza la mano
sinistra
abbiamo provato la presa di forza è
molto forte veramente e quindi riesco
veramente a portare a borsa della spesa
questo mi dispiace che non l'hai fatto
vedere perché veramente si porta la
borsa della spesa e all iper all'altra
mano per tutte le evenienze
quindi mi rimane solo a dire grazie
dati davvero tanto all'ingegneria
catalizzo ea tutto il suo staff compreso
nel genere grati ai nostri cari
finisco gli sto dicendo che il nostro
laboratorio e un laboratorio che human
center ed centrato su noi sviluppiamo
robotica per l'uomo per migliorare la
qualità della vita delle persone che ne
hanno bisogno
ed è un laboratorio che è nato a siena è
nato una in una città di provincia
splendida come quella di siena che di
provincia solo geograficamente perché
gioca un ruolo centrale in uno dei
network più importanti di robotica per
ricerca innovazione e questo grazie alla
rete grazie alla possibilità di essere
permanentemente connessi
c'è questa grande chance che abbiamo in
questo in questo millennio di poter
lavorare ovunque noi vogliamo con i
migliori mezzi con le migliori menti
sfruttando al meglio la bellezza e la
qualità della vita che possiamo avere in
città di provincia come quella di siena
grazie grazie
[Musica]